Well, well our war hero has arrived.
‘Killers of the Flower Moon’
was a series of murders
of Osage men and women,
to bilk them after the discovery
of oil on their land.
The Osage reign of terror
was a fascinating piece of American history.
I was drawn to the idea to tell this terribly
tragic story that
was never brought to national attention.
Marty’s obsessed with telling this story with
the most honesty that he possibly could.
One of the key things,
was that I was drawn to this world
where friendship and love existed
with blatant extortion, exploitation, and murder.
When this money start coming,
we should’ve known it came with something else.
In our film, Ernest develops a relationship
with Mollie Burkhardt.
I don’t know what you said,
but it must’ve been Indian for handsome devil.
Ernest was encouraged to marry her
by his uncle Bill Hale.
In order to get her family
shares in the oil profits.
Hale was a very enigmatic presence in Osage country.
He definitely represented somebody
that wanted to take advantage
of the situation at all costs.
Their time is over.
There was a need to tell this story
from Martin Scorsese.
There was something intrinsic
in him to do this story justice.
There’s a sinister nature
of the murders of the Osage people.
Expecting a miracle to make this all go away?
You know they don’t happen anymore.
I wanted to do justice to the Osage.
So that the audience feels
the immensity of the tragedy.